did you hear the news reports have been
trickling in for a number of years now
that after a long slow decline trash
talk in Esports is finally dead but how
true is that
oh here we go this is what I want sorry
all right before we get into this I want
to remind you the spring is on the way
and pretty soon you'll want to go
outside for a little bit maybe touch
some grass and we have the perfect
hoodie for you to wear while you're
doing that our touchgrass hoodie it's
part of a whole new collection of merch
we have over on our website so go and
check that out using the link in the
description box alright so let me take
you back a few weeks now to when
something pretty spicy happen after
Cloud9 beat Team Liquid in the LCS see
if you can catch him yeah wow oh man the
cold handshake oh oh what the heck is
actually going on did you catch it that
was Cloud9 supports then refusing to
shake hands with Team Liquid 80 carry
yawn Ben said shortly after that he
didn't Shake Yan's hand because during
the game he'd called them worse than
their Academy team after they lost a
team fight he said he thought it was
distasteful to talk like that but that
in hindsight he thought he was a bit out
of line as well and apologized to yon
and everyone kind of kicked off about
all of this we had articles and Reddit
threads explain tightening the drama and
a reply from Jan himself saying it's not
worth an apology and I know I'm kind of
doing the same right now but it's for a
larger point because all of this got me
thinking has Esports gone a bit soft
how's the trash talk we all once knew
just died in League's early days the
trash talk was undoubtedly spicier and
players like doublelift never held back
I guess if we get upset that would be
pretty embarrassing so we're gonna take
it obviously very seriously just like we
take every match I just think they're by
far the worst team in LCS what I love
about that clip is that he actually went
on to lose that game good stuff but at
the risk of generalizing here I think
it's fair to say that League of Legends
has never been the best place to go to
for trash talking people like to point
back at things like Jensen saying he's
gonna clap fakers some sort of Premium
trash talk for me though that was
obviously tongue-in-cheek and as much as
we can all enjoy that kind of stuff it's
pretty mild but there are of course
other games where it's far from that
like Call of Duty
guys boys
let's go you're watching me play and
even though some of the classics are
almost a decade all at this point the
current trash talking in the scene is
still
baby I swear to God
yo Dempsey you better you me brother
cause I got a lot to say about you
you lost his shirts you lost a hard
point I've been playing this game for
five days and you still got put in a
body bag you need to do something else
brother because this hobby ain't right
for you oh God has also given us so many
instances of players shouting
obscenities at each other across a stage
to the point where it's now become
synonymous with FPS games while CS goes
Trash Talk might not be quite as in your
face as Cod we've definitely seen
players talk over the years so what are
your words for Kenny s and G2 who you're
going to be facing off against tomorrow
good luck Kenny I'll [__] you up
[Applause]
what's up there is some debate about
whether trash talk in Tier 1 CS go is as
common as it used to be some people I've
spoken to said that things were already
getting pretty tame in the scene by the
time the pandemic brought about the
online era which only furthered its
demise But Trash Talk is undeniably
Alive and Well in csgo's lower tiers
just last week a player at a UK Lan
event lost his team the entire game by
standing up the trash talk instead of
defusing the bomb on Match Point
[Music]
oh
my God
of course one corner of Esports that has
Trash Talk written into the fabric of
its DNA is fighting games there's gonna
come a point when you forget about what
happened and you're gonna want to come
back at me
and you're going to want to watch the
taste of my dick out of your mouth
[Applause]
you made it here you're on the big stage
finally you're here but as a person I
just don't like him I just don't like
him straight up what are your thoughts
on that man who gives them
but even though the fgc displays what we
would call Classic trash talk it's not
immune to change many have complained
that talking has all but disappeared
from the scene but there's also a new
wave that's questioning whether or not
it's even necessary these days or
pointing out that in some cases the
community is just better at identifying
when Trash Talk crosses that line into
bullying and even if you're a fan of
trash talk this is obviously something
that it has to contend with that you're
only ever a few poorly chosen words away
from it just being straight up toxic it
has to walk this tightrope between both
full competition and bullying now it's
clear that there's changing cultural
attitudes much larger than Esports going
on here as well pretty much every
industry in the world has made visible
efforts in recent years to distance
themselves from anything that could be
perceived as harassing toxic or
derogatory behavior and Esports is no
different the question is has Trash Talk
become collateral damage in pursuit of
that or did it need to be cleaned up
eventually because one major factor in
all of this is the ongoing
professionalization of Esports while
there are some exceptions it's generally
true that if Publishers League owners
and tournament organizers want to
attract big advertisers they can't
really have players threatening to
teabag each other across a stage on
broadcast and if there's one company
that this might be ringing a bell for
you with I'm guessing it's riot in
November last year Shopify Rebellion
coach Rob was celebrated his team's win
in the game changers championship and
threw up his middle finger across the
stage at the defeated Cloud9 white Riot
suspended him for his next game which
happened to be the grand finals and
stated he breached a rule that requires
coaches to quote observe the highest
standards of personal integrity and good
sportsmanship at all times the responses
were a mixture of confusion accusations
of hypocrisy and a sense that this was
all a bit over the top but Riot throwing
the book at someone like this for a
middle finger let everyone know where
they stand on players and coaches trash
walking during a broadcast look it's
hard to quantify if there truly has been
a decline in trash talk in Esports over
the years it's not really something you
can plot on a graph and see a hard
correlation those that have witnessed
this scene rise out of scuffed basement
lands to corporate sponsored Stadium
events can see that things have changed
and that isn't necessarily bad in many
ways Esports has become a place where
Pros can expect to do their job without
having insults held at them fans have
arguably more inclusive and less toxic
scenes to enjoy and everything has
become more Advertiser and mainstream
friendly this raises questions though
primarily is there room for trash talk
in this Esports if there is what does it
look like where is the line where it
morphs into toxicity who gets to draw
that line and when I'm sure I don't need
to sell trash talk in its healthiest
form to any of you watching this I'm
sure we can all agree that when it's
done right it adds a whole new dimension
to Competitive Gaming one that can't be
replicated in game or by corporate
driven narratives if communities can
answer those questions and find where it
fits into modern Esports then trash talk
will continue to have its time and place
but if it can't do that well is trash
talk dead
gonna say Cod like an actual person keep
saying qualities
yeah every single time I'm like I'm just
like I'm just like when when people are
playing the game known as the call of
the duty that's what it sounds like
playing the game hear the call of the
duty